public health officials are bracing for
yet another uptick of coronavirus
infections and deaths
following recent christmas and new
year's gatherings it's putting new
pressure on the nation's already
strained health care system especially
in california
where some hospitals are on the verge of
rationing care
on friday there were more than 160 000
new infections in the united states
it pushed the total number of cases
above 20
million while the death toll from the
virus has reached 347 thousand lives
all this as a new contagious variant of
the virus appears to be spreading
tom hansen has the latest here in new
york this morning good morning tom
good morning jerica well hospitals are
on high alert for that new more
contagious strain that first
surfaced in england then it popped up in
colorado california
and now it's in florida the fast-moving
virus arrives as cases continue to rise
at an unrelenting pace
california's death toll climbed by 585
lives on new year's day the same day 47
thousand new confirmed cases were
reported there
swelling the caseload in hospitals scott
brickner is a nurse at cedars-sinai
hospital in los angeles it's like
treading water from 100 feet below the
surface
you're already drowning but you just
have to keep trying because that's what
you can do
nationally 40 percent of new cases are
in southern states
texas hospitalization broke records five
days straight
up 36 percent in the last month against
this background defiant crowds danced in
philadelphia to protest the cancellation
of the new year's day parade
and religious worshipers protested
california's limits on indoor gatherings
there's greater good in being here than
there is being afraid of a virus
still in los angeles the epicenter of
the virus
a person dies every 10 minutes
and the best hope to thwart the virus
the vaccines
was sullied too a wisconsin pharmacist
is in police custody after admitting to
tampering with vials of the vaccine
given at an aurora health center
the individual was suspended and
admitted to intentionally removing the
vaccine from refrigeration
the matter is now under a criminal
investigation
the 57 recipients of those vaccines have
been notified
at this time there is no evidence that
the vaccinations pose any harm to them
even under the best circumstances
inoculating a nation has been very
difficult so far
20 million first doses were supposed to
be in people's arms this week
but just 12 and a half million doses
were distributed
and less than three million have
actually been administered
four-star general gus perna is in charge
of vaccine distribution
it's been just 12 days there's two
holidays
there's been three major snowstorms and
i believe
that uptake will increase significantly
and new york city mayor bill de blasio
says the goal is to vaccinate 1 million
people by the end of january
the city has received 360 000 doses
they've administered about 98 000
and vaccine hubs will be launched to
help speed up the distribution
dana slow going a lot of questions about
that that we will get into tom thank you